الى المنطقه
عن طريق الفرق الميدانيه للوصول الى هذه
الاصابه داخل المخيم
جميع مداخل الموقع مغلقات بشكل كامل
سيارات الاسعاف في محيط المخيم تحاول
الوصول والدخول الى
المخيم ولكن قوات الاحتلال الى الان
السيارات
قلت اصابه واحده داخل المخيم لا تستطيعون
الوصول اليها السيد احمد ام عدد اكبر من
الاصابات
يعني الان وصلتني اشاره عن استلام نصابه
اخرى من داخل المخيم لاحد
الشبه اصابه في منطقه البطن وجاري نقله
الى مستشفى رفيقي
لاستكمال العلاج ما طبيعه هذه الاصابه
يعني اصابه في منطقه البطن رصاص في منطقه
يعني
منطقه
الاصابه بالتحديد
حسب الايطاليه للنقل الى اي مستشفى
بالتالي نحن
امام اصابتين مؤكدتين وصلتا الى المستشفى
نعم صحيح
الطبيه التابعه لجمع
وجاري نقلها الى مستشفى رفيديا لاستكمال
العلاج الاصابه في منطقه
البطن والحوض الاصابه في منطقه الان يتم
التاكيد بعد الفحص من قبل التواصل لديه
اصابه في منطقه البطن ومنطقه الحوض وهذه
الاصابات طلعت من الاصابات الخاطره
هل علمتم
متى اصيب واين اصيب هذان الفلسطينيين ان
كان في المواجهات التي جرت عقب اقتحام
المخيم مخيم بلاطه او اين
يعني صحيح الاصابات داخل
المخيميدانيه تابعه على جمعيه الهلال
الاحمر
للوصول الى هذه الاصابات من من طرق فرعيه
للوصول وذلك بسبب منع قوات الاحتلال
السيارات
داخل والدخول داخل
سياره الشباك الى شغله المنطقه بشكل
كائن في محيط المنطقه الان يتم نقل
الاصابه هناك مواجهات في محيط المخيم بشكل
كامل ولكن قوات الاحتلال الى الان تمنع
السيارات
الان الاصابه في
اربعه رصاصات في في البطن
الاصابه اربع اصابات في منطقه
البطن الان جريمه الى مستشفى رفيديا